A few days ago,
a racially insensitive email surfaced
from UBA board president, Cybil Reynolds.
The email contained comments about me.
I haven't spoken out in public until now.
And here to join me as I do so is
the woman who wrote those comments.
UBA board president, Cybil Reynolds,
thank you for being here.
Thank you for having me on.
Now I know there was some furor,
well deserved,
over the statement that UBA
issued some days ago.
It was inadequate, to say the very least.
The mistake was mine and mine alone,
and I'm here to apologize in person.
Chris, I'm--
I am deeply sorry for what I said.
Even in the heat of
a contentious hiring decision,
nothing can excuse what I said.
You mean calling me Aunt Jemima?
I didn't exactly call you Aunt--
I wanna set the record straight.
You know that Aunt Jemima was on boxes
of pancake mix and not cereal, right?
I guess I know that now.
But this is about more than
just an offhand comment.
The irony of your joke is that
the Pearl Milling Company
used the image and likeness of
a Black woman to sell a brand,
I'm sure, with no profit participation.
My question is what brand
am I helping UBA to sell, in your eyes?
Look, words matter. Actions matter more.
And UBA has been sorely inactive
when it comes to equity and inclusion.
Now, the board isn't involved
with day-to-day operations.
We leave that to
the capable leadership of our CEO.
But when that leadership falters,
I have a duty to step in.
Don't you f*cking dare.
-She firing shots at Cory?
-He deserves them.
I'm not sure you're answering my question.
-Oh.
-But let's talk about stepping in.
What would that look like?
Do you even think it's possible
to win back the trust of UBA's employees?
You know something? I do.
I do think it's possible.
And it'll start with a dialogue
between UBA employees and the board.
From now on, you all will have
a voice at every single board meeting.
Now is the time for transparency.
That's great to hear, truly.
In the interest of transparency,
Was I hired for a permanent
anchor position because I am Black?
Obviously not. No.
But you see my confusion, right?
Because you used a clumsy racist comment
to complain about my hiring.
Did you think I wasn't qualified,
was that it?
Well, now in point of fact, at that time,
I did not believe you were qualified.
Let me rephrase. You were untested.
Well, that's not exactly true.
Were you aware that I was cue tested
more than any other person who
has ever anchored this show?
That I had to have eight different
approval meetings
in addition to the strategy discussions
about my hair?
I was unaware.
And I still found time to
spend weekends with four former anchors,
developing my on-air skills.
Well, now that-that is impressive.
That's very admirable.
That aside,
I don't understand why you used
a racialized image when discussing me.
Is that how you see me?
Is that how you see us?
Would you want your entire career
reduced to one unthinking,
bone-headed thing you said in an email?
Haven't you ever said anything
that later you came to regret
when speaking casually?
You're in a leadership position
at this network.
And on your watch,
you let employees of color
be systematically devalued.
Is that something to be casual about?
Donny,
tell the camera to push in on Cybil,
-and keep pushing until I see her pores.
-We're supposed to break.
-You want me to cut--
-No. No.
Okay. Camera two, push in. Closer.
No.
I was careless,
and there isn't any excuse.
But you have to understand.
We don't just give this opportunity
to anyone.
Anyone who sits in that chair
has to be grateful--
I sh--
There it is.
I should be grateful?
Well,
that your job is so very hard to get.
I want to say,
as for UBA as an institution,
going forward, I think we've--
We should move on from this climate
where racial divisions are exploited.
But that's every climate though,
wouldn't you say?
Sh*t.
But yes,
we will move on from institutional racism
right after this break.